[Musique]
hélène budget ti michel david christian
dufour bon choix bonsoir bonsoir les
barrages
michel david
vous avez couvert sa début des années 90
jusqu'en 94 je me suis parfois du bon
ben on le fera pas
le
grande baleine qui était le dernier gros
gros groupes projets et les gens
venaient un canot ici avait de
l'opposition partout avec les
autochtones c'est compliqué est ce que
monsieur le groupe on veut l'entendre
dire saut ce matin je vais vous demander
est-ce que c'était le moment est ce
qu'ils demandent vraiment avec draw
québec de presser le poste qu'il a
raison pas on écoute
c'est pour ça que je vous annonce ce
matin
que je vais demander à hydro-québec de
regarder la possibilité de construire
des nouveaux barrages au québec pour
avoir d'énergies propres additionnels
d'un grand geste
ça fait rêver michel ça nous renvoie
robert bourassa ça nous renvoie aux
grands ouvrages québécois ouais mais ça
nous renvoie aussi aux autochtones qui
descendait la rivière hudson à aux états
unis pour protester contre contre ce
développement là alors
écoutez je peux vraiment surpris dans la
mesure où souvenez vous il ya pas très
longtemps monsieur legault avait
commencé à parler de la baie james du
21e siècle de québec était pour cela
c'est la daille il y avait
dans son esprit d'associer même d'autres
provinces au coût de construction des
transports bon on connaît la suite en
ontario on a dit d'abord basée à mwene
ensuite monsieur x redis on n'est pas
intéresser du tout alors on avait
l'impression que c'était un peu mis sous
le boisseau mais je pense que dans la
tête de monsieur legault stress était
toujours là et mon impression pourquoi
il y arriver avec ça aujourd'hui je
pense que dans son esprit ça va donner
un peu de crédibilité à ses prétentions
de faire passer l'ensemble de l'économie
de l'énergie fossile à l'énergie
renouvelable la au cours des derniers
jours on a vu les autres parties qui
développent qui dévoilent leur plan de
lutte contre les changements climatiques
et à n'être pas celui de l'a4 à l'air un
peu pâlot la coutume achéens d'espèce il
manquait de
monsieur je pense que monsieur legault
se disait un des barrages sa voiture
environ les jambes on voit qu'on est
sérieux alors je sais pas si ça va
marcher mais c'est vous le disiez tantôt
le nombre d'obstacles qui vont se
présenter sur la route l'eau d'ici là
c'est considérable c'est juste le début
de l'histoire et dota que je rappelle ce
n'était pas avec nous plutôt sophie
brochu elle-même il ya trois mois en
entrevue même pas nous disent il ya
trois mois il me disait on à l'obsession
des castors elle aurait pu dire comme
quelqu'un a autrefois le syndrome de la
pépine moi j'veux pas là-dedans leur âge
et leur efficacité d'abord on va
moderniser les ouvrages qu'on a et
peut-être un jour on va peut-être
envisagée mais c'était petit petit petit
loin loin loin loin christian walch
bonne idée en fait sur le papier non non
ça va bien ça rappelle vraiment d'aidé
souvenirs et exaltant de l'histoire
moderne du québec faut-il rappeler que
qu'aujourd'hui on profite d'un capital
hydroélectrique qui nous ont légué les
générations antérieures qui fait le
bilan du québec en matière de
d'émissions de gaz à effet serre et
meilleur nettement meilleure que le
reste du canada la majorité des pays
développés et monsieur legault le dis
souvent est scellée en matière
écologique au québec je trouve ça
correspond pas à la réalité il faut
faire des choses faut être sérieux la
question que ça pose en fait ce qu'on
est encore capable au québec de faire
des grands projets est bon le troisième
ligne je pense que le troisième lien je
veux pas que ce soit comme un espèce de
modèles bon parce que tout on voit les
problèmes les autres bon la baie james
robert bourassa à l'époque il s'est fait
mépriser s'est fait critiquer il ya eu
des problèmes avec les autochtones et
tout ça bien fini et ça aboutit avec la
première entente avec les autochtones
des temps modernes qui marche dans le
québec peut être très fier donc moi je
trouve entre motion go positif là ça
nous sort du début de campagne avec des
banques est un peu pathétique je trouve
au aux citoyens monsieur legault lance
quelque chose qui peut être simulé puis
aussi qui va dans le sens de notre force
hydraulique triste et c'est notre force
on en profite maintenant mais là les
problèmes commencent c'est sûr et puis
rasé bonne idée je garde ça va marcher
mais sam du courage dont a fait preuve
je trouve que le québec d'aujourd'hui le
cauchemar est ce qu'on est capable de
faire des affaires ln oui ben en fait
l'idée elle circule depuis longtemps
vous avez raison de mentionner que
madame brochu 10 heures au dépôt là du
tout même temps je te retourner un petit
peu dans les archives et son
prédécesseur monsieur martel lui avait
dit ben on a peut-être encore de la
place pour un nom petits projets
d'exportation après faudrait pas de
temps de songer à justement augmenter
notre capacité bref c'est dans l'air
depuis un certain temps mais c'est
certainement pas aux politiques de
déterminer les besoins énergétiques du
québec je pense qu'il ferait mieux de
laisser aux experts d'hydro-québec
déterminer quelle est notre besoins
quels sont nos besoins comment les
allées il répond qu est ce qu il faut
construire ou non des barrages je trouve
l'analyse de michel assez intéressante
sur le fait qu'il a voulu peut-être se
donner une crédibilité environnementale
mais moi j'ajouterai une autre course
bush je pense que ça procède de cette
stratégie électorale de la part de la
caq de venir titiller la fibre
nationaliste identitaire nous sommes un
grand peuple nous sommes comme vient
encore de faire de grandes choses ça
s'inscrit dans cette campagne
identitaire de la caq mais est ce que
les fai soutiennent ce besoin a affirmé
à la politique est ce que la logique
économique est ce qu'on est rendus là
peut-être et c'est sûr que le dira mais
parce qu'il ya le coût de construction
et le coût kilowattheure l'été c'est
quand même assez technique oui christian
futur qui restait sûr que des millions
de sacs le rire est faux que l'impulsion
politique n'y avait pas d'obstacle
question je dis est ce que les faits non
je sais cela arrive est-ce que les faits
françois qu'on arrive à la conclusion
qu'on a besoin c'est comme le troisième
question d'obstacles c'est ce que les
faits mais bon peut-être que oui mais là
on est en commun électoral en campagne
électorale c'est le premier du québec
trouve ça important l'impulsion
politique de lancer l'idée de faire
rêver un peu mais moi je vous avoue que
je trempais smith je pense pour savoir
ce que les gens les québécois vont juste
voir les obstacles qu'on est rendus là
on voit les autres ça pour voir les
obstacles on débat capable ok il aime
souligner et on veut aussi voir
démonstration économique que c'est
nécessaire michel david le stop au sort
puis si je veux parce que la crise nous
apparaît troisième lien c'est ça que les
gens demandent au 1er mai c'est michel
donnez-nous les chiffres pour justifier
le besoin impérieux besoin dès lors on
peut tous participent également au
projet là vous savez le gouvernement est
l'actionnaire non seulement majoritaire
mais au québec et quand il dit nous
autres on veut des barrages je pense que
la commande c'est à hydro québec s'est
trouvé une ou un argumentaire favorable
nous on veut qu'à la fin de la journée
là vous nous disiez qu'il faut faire ça
et pensions compris alors non moi je et
je suis d'accord avec avec russian en
bout de ligne bon je comprends que pour
toute la partie technique désigner quel
rivières etc c'est à hydro de faire
cesser ces devoirs mais la décision a
revient aux élus et si monsieur legault
ou le gouvernement je sais pas combien
de temps monsieur legault va être là
mais décide quand il va on va y aller
quel instant brain pour construire un
barrage puis les idées aujourd'hui je
passe un point de presse écoutez je
pense que les gens pas envie de me
mettre à la porte tout de suite on verra
si je serai encore lui a fait une blague
très bien c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait laisser aussi c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait laisser votre parti
vous permettez
je trouve intéressant quand même si
cette levée de boucliers sur par rapport
à aux barrages même le fait de dire hey
ça pollue ça détruit des territoires et
tout ça est vrai mais je trouve que ça
démontre un peu la lacune discours
actuel environnemental où on est toutes
au climat l'on parle de
l'électrification au terrain c'est bien
mais on oublie que l'électricité peut
même si les kids ro elle peut causer une
autre forme de pollution la
déforestation
la destruction de paysages et bref il
faut pas juste faire la transition
énergétique il faut aussi par la
réduction énergétique son oubli beaucoup
je pense dans l'équation en ce moment
c'est la même logique avec les voitures
électriques les gens mais attention si
on remplace toutes les voitures à
essence par des voitures électriques il
faut qu'on réduise le le nombre de
voitures en absolu c'est ce bon après je
vais vous parler des anglophones du
parti conservateur du québec monsieur
duhaime on écoute monsieur duhaime on
écoute madame anglade tomber
les anglophones ont intérêt à faire
partie d'une plus large alliance avec
des francophones qui partage leurs
valeurs fondamentales qui partage leurs
valeurs de respect des droits de respect
des libertés de respect de la démocratie
et c'est pour ça que je demande aux
anglophones de nous envoyer des députés
conservateurs anglophones à l'assemblée
nationale le 3 octobre au soir on veut
qu'à l'intérieur de notre caucus votre
voix soit entendue vous avez été les
otages trop longtemps du parti libéral
du québec
moi je vous dirais que ce que les gens
ont envie d'entendre c'est une formation
politique est capable de rallier la
population d'arrêter de diviser entre
francophones et anglophones d'arrêter de
diviser entre immigrants non immigrants
c'est exactement ce que fait le parti
libéral du québec et quand je parle à la
communauté d'expression anglaise quand
on tient ce discours là puis ça vient
vraiment dans nos tripes ils l'entendent
ce discours là ils le reconnaissent il
reconnaît ses valeurs
alors je commence avec vous christian
tour de table rapide qu'est ce que éric
duhaime tente de faire là bas il situe
vraiment en dehors d'un certain
consensus nationalistes québécois puis
profite en fait de la faiblesse qui
était notée partout nom du véhicule
traditionnel des anglo-québécois le
parti libéral bon qu'est ce que ça va
donner en pratique mais il reste quand
même ça ça déstabilise un peu le système
c'est révélateur aussi que c'est quand
même un libertarien au départ bon ça
reste encore comme philosophie donc lui
veux pas qu'on utilise la clause
nonobstant il veut pas enlever des
droits pour c'est une chose qui est
intéressante c'est à sa base politique
au départ
or on sait que la région de québec et
patrick gachon analystes historiquement
on a souvent dit que si la région de
québec avaient voté autant oui que le
reste du québec c'est louis kiehl leur
rapporter l'or lors des référendums dans
quelque chose d'intéressant de nouveau
parce que et on est en même temps
j'écoutais votre débat très intéressant
parfaite semaine
j'aime mieux ce qui est des bons mots
sur ce genre d'affairé mais georges
écrivent ça me va des bols 20 de shell
mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il
était chanceux eric tu aimes lors de
cette enveloppe à ce que vous semblez
très très très bien tiré parce qu'on lui
a pas posé de questions là dessus sur la
langue sur les armes sur ces choses le
rmi l'horloge et est ce que je veux dire
c'est que ça paraisse une vulnérabilité
marcato moi c'est une originalité s'ils
me font très bien michel oui bah ya un
fond on le voit dans les sondages
anglophones à montréal qui appuient le
parti conservateur c'est 15% je pense
des non francophones qui actuellement à
free parti conservateur pour 19% je
pense c'est le deuxième choix ils feront
pas élire deux députés là dans région
montréal on s'entend mais ça pourrait
nuire considérablement
aux libéraux un peu comme ça avait été
le cas si souvenez-vous patrice 176 le
camp l'union nationale avait fait pas
mal de millage là en blâmant les
libéraux pour la loi 22 et savait
contribue beaucoup à la victoire du pq à
l'époque mais ceci étant dit monsieur
duhaime quand ils utilisent les
anglophones cézallier du français lors
il faut pas charrier le les anglophones
sont pas leur faire le combat pour le
français et et d'autre part on passe à
côté de l'enjeu c'est pas les
anglophones et les allophones qui sont
l'enjeu de touche à la loi 96 le vise
pas à franciser les anglophones dessous
je sais pas ça du tout l'idée c'est
d'inciter les allophones les nouveaux
arrivants à s'intégrer à la communauté
francophone et ça monsieur monsieur
duhaime fait abstraction de tout ça
quand ils nous ont fait table rase la
loi 96 et dans les politiques qu'on
retrouve le pendant d'un programme
libéral pas grave un conservateur il n'y
a aucune aucune mesure qui implique la
moindre coercition on retombe dans
l'incitation dont on sait depuis 50 ans
que ça mène à rien alors je trouve que
c'est pas c'est pas bon pour le français
lorsque monsieur
cours commente ça témoigne la faiblesse
de madame anglade ça pourrait peut-être
faire le jeu de la caq dans certaines
circonscriptions montréalaises détenus
par des libéraux obtenu très serré le
comme à berlin une petite baisse de leur
appui au profit du conservateur ça
pourrait faire faufiler la cac monsieur
duhaime je pense joue quand même un jeu
dangereux parce que oui il est surtout
appuyés par des francophones dans la
région de québec et il pourrait en
faisant se retrouver écartelé de la même
manière que le parti libéral le toujours
été entre les la protection des intérêts
de la communauté anglophone et les les
élans un peu plus identitaire si je peux
dire des francophones je suis pas
certain de comprendre pourquoi il fait
ce calcul genevois quoi ce king
longueuil à gagner à faire quelques
votes le résultat dureront pas par des
sièges de cette manière je vous
entendent avant de vous quitter sur
la fracture idéologique là on voyait
deux philosophies q est-ce libéraux d'un
côté pour les jeux vous parle de
l'immigration
donc on ouvre les bras puis on va on
fait le pari que ces gens devront se
francise etc et de l'autre côté parti
québécois et la cadre qui
christian il on ne peut pas suivre le
rythme canadien puis il faut refermer
les portes on peut pas faire entre
autant de monde donc le ya deux offres
très différent des deux fois juste des
chiffres il ya deux philosophies
différentes christian et c'est un très
beau débauche oreilles même des bonus
sous sap puis dès qu'ils n'ont pas
l'heur de déraper parce que vous savez
dans les campagnes électorales
antérieures quand on parler
d'immigration tout le monde de s'énerver
l'enjeu est fondamental est assez simple
au fond ainsi que la priorité c'est de
maintenir le caractère français du
québec à 80% à peu près où est ce que
c'est de me dire le poids du québec au
sein du canada un québec qui
souhaiterait moins francophones parce
qu'on est dans un pays qu'on le dit
souvent reçoit beaucoup d'immigrants
c'est vrai qu'on ne retrouve plus
proportionnellement que la france il se
saisit mon nez dans un pays qu'ils
soient ok le plus haut est bien engagée
et moi je veux juste dire que quand à
moi c'est clair que le choix ça doit
être de maintenir le caractère il
renseigne québec et non pas d'être
dépendant de la dynamique canadienne ils
sont en train de vouloir recevoir 450
mille immigrés notre chemin capable de
les sourires ça tremble et christian va
y revenir mais je vais attendre michel
l'autre l'autre élément important je
pense dans ce débat là c est ce que il
faut se fier sur l'immigration pour
régler nos problèmes économiques de
pénurie de main d'oeuvre ou si c'est
l'aspect identitaire de l'immigration
qui doit être privilégiée
et ça c'est un
débat éternel et j'ajouterai un
troisième joueur du côté de ceux qui
veulent limiter l'immigration c'est les
conservateurs quand même monsieur
monsieur deuxième lui malus avait pas de
niege
bailly venu nous visiter aujourd'hui
d'avoir mis 50 minutes
ok ça car très bien quand hélène et you
higher débat juste deux chefs mais
philosophique derrière c'est ça que je
voulais souligner la wii et vous avez
posé je pense dimanche soir patrice la
question qui tue est ce que on est en
train de signer le déclin du québec au
sein du canada mais en fait soyons
honnêtes même ceux comme québec
solidaire et le parti libéral qui
propulse des migrations même leurs
chiffres à eux seraient est insuffisant
par rapport à ce que le canada veut
faire si on voulait maintenir le rythme
et canadien il faudrait qu'on accueille
s'en mêler mais durant au québec
personnes suggèrent ça et donc quoi
qu'il arrive le poids démographique du
québec va diminuer plus ou moins
rapidement et je pense que ça interpelle
le fédéral savoir est ce que cette cible
que personne au fédéral de contest en
france à part maxime bernier et ont
peut-être qu'il serait temps d'avoir un
débat là-dessus pour justement si on dit
que la nation québécoise est important
le fait français et bien pas de cette
interrogation et je pense que je pense
parce qu on oublie un peu dans le bois
de la campagne souvenez vous que
une au printemps monsieur legault avait
pas mal
annoncé clairement qu'il y aurait une
manière de d'états généraux de
conversation nationale souvent parler la
prochaine fois pas sinon le prévenu a
confié dans l'émission de gérald merci
merci à vous tous